My therapist said
to me once, you know,
Ru, the power you
have in drag is
available to you out of drag.
Exsqueeze me?
For years, I've said you're born
naked, and the rest is drag,
meaning everything you
put on is, in essence,
something that was
built. And once you're
able to see yourself
from outside of yourself,
that's when the party begins.
In this MasterClass, I'm going
to teach you about self-love,
confidence, joy, lips,
foundation, wigs, chiffon--
everything it takes to unleash
the magic that makes you you.
What you're going to see
is Raven show you, step
by step, what it takes to
get into real, glamazon drag.
Drag doesn't change who you are.
It actually reveals who you are.
My childhood was very
tumultuous and traumatic.
My parents were always at war.
So my thinking was, this
is all too much for me.
Just wake me when it's done.
Until I realized, you know, I
want to be present for my life.
And it forced me to
understand my own value.
Everything starts
with know thyself.
Know what works with you.
You have to be present enough
to know what feels right.
In drag, I feel so powerful.
It is your life's work to shine.
There is strength and power
in you, but it's up to you
to realize it.
You were not born to fit in.
You were born to stand out.
I'm RuPaul, and this
is my MasterClass.